[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tous mercredi à
30 mais bienvenue dans le journal de tv
soixante dix huit ce soir en édition
spéciale tout de suite les titres de
cette émission il est notre invité
pierre bédier sera avec nous tout au
long de cette édition le président les
républicains du conseil départemental
des yvelines commentera l'actualité
locale et nationale menace terroriste
est discours sur les banlieues des
manuels macron et préparation des jo de
elle nous parlerons également de
l'action du département pierre bédier
qui est candidat pour la présidence de
la fédération les républicains des
yvelines l'élection se tiendra en
octobre pour désigner le successeur de
david douillet et pour ce scrutin il
fera face notamment à la vice-présidente
du conseil régional d'ile-de-france
alexandra du blanche enfin l'essentiel
de l'actualité locale pas de successeur
encore pour jean-pierre sevestre à saint
quentin en yvelines les semaine du
développement durable sur le territoire
et puis reportage sur le cactus qui fait
fureur en ce moment dans le département
sans plus tarder on accueille notre
invité fil rouge de cette émission
pierre bédier bonsoir bonsoir président
à l'est républicain du conseil
départemental des yvelines également
candidats pour elles à prendre la tête
de la fédération ait l'air sur le
territoire on en parlera plus tard dans
cette émission votre réaction déjà sur
quelques sujets est d'actualité cette
attaque terroriste d'abord allié d'hier
en belgique
un homme a tué trois personnes dont deux
policiers ça fait forcément écho à ce
qui s'était passé en 2016 à magnanville
l'assassinât d'un couple de policiers
alors le département s'est lancé dans le
déploiement de 3000 à 4000 caméras de
surveillance sur le territoire c'est un
système intelligent qui se déclenche en
cas de son et d'image suspecte et qui
sera placée notamment autour des écoles
des casernes de deux pompiers quand vous
voyez pierre bédier cette actualité
cette triste actualité en belgique cela
vous conforte encore plus dans cette
action dans le lancement de cette action
totalement
alors on ne pourra jamais totalement
prévenir ces actions qui sont soit
l'objet de terroristes
relativement indécelable soit de dengue
celui l'on s'est pas encore trop près ce
que j'ai compris c'est peut-être même
les deux mais c'est vrai que la
prévention peut être largement renforcée
par la technologie sur le calendrier où
on nettoyait une phase pilote qui a été
lancé ses 100 ans aujourd'hui il ya à la
fois une phase pilote il ya aussi des
commandes ihd lacune législative
c'est-à-dire il faudrait une adaptation
de la loi pour qu'on puisse avoir une
surveillance qu'ils soient plus
performantes
donc tout ça est en cours de déploiement
avec une priorité les collèges puisque
c'est de notre responsabilité
autre actualité de ce début de semaine
la mort de serge dassault à l'âge de 93
ans était lundi industriel bien sûr
hommes politiques également l'ancien
sénateur de l'essonne avait un
pied-à-terre à coignières il y avait une
propriété que retenez vous de lui est ce
que c'est le capitaine d'industrie ou où
l'homme politique peut-être les deux
aussi aux essais les deux parce que
c'est un personnage hors norme d'abord
l'homme politique qu'il était allé se
frotter à une colline difficile dans un
combat très dur contre un maire
communiste comme l aigle au sol un
essonne alors qu'il aurait pu très
légitimement choisir un endroit plus
paisible
et puis c'est est un capitaine
d'industrie un visionnaire et dois-je
rappeler qu une des perles industriels
venus des perles entrepreneuriale pardon
du département des yvelines
c'est dassault systèmes qui est installé
à vélizy qui est une entreprise
exceptionnelle autant les avions
d'assaut c'est marcel autant dassault
systèmes c'est serge quelle ligne est
exceptionnel d'entrepreneurs dernier
sujet avant de passer à autre chose il
remonte à la semaine dernière mardi 22
mai manuel macron a fait un discours sur
les banlieues hors pas de grands plans
en banlieue annoncé comme le président
le préconisait jean louis borloo dans un
rapport mais quelques projets annoncés
notamment 30000 stages pour les élèves
de 3e avec une bourse de stage également
qu'il sera mise en place
vous avez dénoncé dans un communiqué
pierre bédier l'absence de mesures
concrètes dans ce discours qui nie
finalement selon vous qu une succession
de généralités pourquoi
je pense que ce gouvernement et ce
présent la république communique bien
mais comme unique voilà on voudrait voir
un peu d'effet je suis originaire des
landes peut-être le savez vous dans les
landes à l'époque du train à vapeur on
se moquait des conducteurs de train
parce que il faisait tellement joué le
sifflet qui finissaient par enlever la
vapeur et que le train arrivait plus
avancé j'espère que le président de la
république ne prend pas hommage exemple
pardon sur ces conducteurs de train à
vapeur des landes
aujourd'hui dans les banlieues fois un
grand plan pour pour aller de l'avant
mais faute d'argent
on nous a annoncé le doublement on va
doubler les crédits comme pour l'instant
on est à 0
si je me souviens bien de mes leçon
d'arithmétique le double de 0 c zéro
donc sans moyens ne se passera rien et
puis on réinvente l'ancien monde
on a créé ce conseil présidents
cherchent d'abord je pense qu'il ya une
personnalisation un peu dangereuse sur
la première fois contré un conseil
présidentiel et ensuite on y met des
personnes qui n'y connaissent pas grand
chose ils ont pour caractéristique
d'être plein de bonne volonté
tant mieux mais il ya 1 66 million de
français comprennent bonne volonté et
ensuite ils ont habité où ils habitent
ces quartiers ils n'ont pas pour autant
une vision d'ensemble et on écarte les
élus qui depuis 30 ans s'échine à faire
avancer ces quartiers alors c'est une
drôle de façon bernard tapie avait
essayé de faire ça ne faisait déjà pas
mal de comme bernard tapie vous souvenez
des résultats de bernard tapie dont jean
louis borloo on s'en souvient et dans
les quartiers les habitants comme les
élus se souviennent qu'ils avaient une
méthode borloo qui marchait pas pourquoi
réinventer le fil à couper le beurre
il suffit de reprendre la méthode borloo
alors pierre bédier vous êtes également
candidat à la vice présidence de la
fédération et les républicains des
débits montants résidence à la
présidence par dont la fédération des
républicains on en parle dans un instant
l'actualité d'abord toujours pas de
remplaçant pour jean-pierre sevestre au
conseil communautaire de saint quentin
en yvelines les élus de l'agglomération
devait tenir hier soir un nouveau vice
président en charge des sports après la
démission du maire de coignières pour
raisons de santé
le vote a été finalement ajourné au mois
de juin entériné dès que packard la
ville pardon la préfecture des yvelines
a pas encore entériné la décision de
jean-pierre semestre
un retard qui tombe mal à quelques mois
de l'organisation de la ryder cup prévue
fin septembre au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines est la préparation
de l'événement s'accélère le poste lui
reste vacant on écoute jean michel
fourgous les propos sont collectées par
un nicolas kirillovitch bien sûr que
c'est on est un peu handicapé dans cette
période parce que c'est un événement qui
est porteur de beaucoup d'activités pour
pour l'agglomération
bien sûr que on est aussi touchée par
parce par ce manque en ce moment qui
dure depuis un peu plus d'un mois donc
on souhaite que ça serait soit résolue
le plus vite possible pour bien
accompagner cet événement très important
de saint quentin
pierre bédier président ait l'air du
conseil départemental des yvelines est
avec nous tout au long de cette édition
spéciale pierre bédier vous avez décidé
au courant de cette année au début de
cette année de vous lancer dans la
course pour la présidence du parti des
républicains dans les yvelines la
fédération les républicains dans les
yvelines
vous avez été maire député secrétaire
d'état sous jacques chirac président
d'une collectivité comme les yvelines
pourquoi là se lancer dans cette
démarche parce que ça va mal ça fait
même très très mal et que ma famille
politique c'est ma famille politique que
parce que ça va mal je considère qu'il
est de ma responsabilité de m'engager
pour ici et ça y est un peu mieux donc
ona trois personnalités emblématiques me
semble-t-il dans le département des
yvelines dont d'ailleurs l'union est
absolument nécessaire
le président du sénat bien entendu ça
n'est pas du niveau du président du
sénat la présidente de région valérie
pécresse qui a gagné avec difficulté
mais beaucoup de courage et de talent
l'élection régionale et qui est donc
concentrer sur son mandat régional et
c'est bien et pour ma part moi zilina
semblait un peu plus tranquille là on a
fait le grand chelem sur mon territoire
j'ai fait réélire le seul député
républicain des jeunes département des
yvelines michel vialay quand je dis j'ai
nous avons pardonnez moi ce
personnalisation abusive et donc j'ai un
peu de temps que je suis prêt et
peut-être un tout petit peu de
d'expérience que je suis prêt à mettre
au service de ma famille politique je
veux pas la voir tomber aussi bas
alors vous avez organisé hier un dîner
débat à plaisir dans le cadre de cette
campagne
écouter ce que disent à ce propos donc
les veaux soutien à lorsque l'on demande
pourquoi votre candidature est la plus
juste à leurs yeux c'est au micro de
nicolas dandois cher tout d'abord pour
moi c'est un humaniste est ce qu il aime
les gens
il aime les autres il aime la diversité
et il comprend les gens
et pour moi ça c'est un facteur clé de
réussite ci pourra nous aider à
reconstruire ensemble dans la
reconstruction du parti aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'hommes d'expérience qui
maîtrise le terrain
et qui connaissent la problématique des
publics n
et qui joue au pouvoir ont le sens des
valeurs des républicains et pierre en
c'est un monsieur qui jusqu'à maintenant
a toujours fait preuve de beaucoup
d'énergie
c'est ce qu'il nous faut nous avons une
période qui était assez calme et
aujourd'hui il va lui falloir que nous
prenions
autre courage à et nous en avons besoin
et pierrette à mon avis le
le seul la seule personne qui puisse
dans notre région
récupérer tout ce qui nous a manqué
jusqu'à maintenant si un homme du
terrain
il est très fort et puis moi je pense
c'est lui le seul homme qui va redresser
la situation de républicains alors
pierre vézien mot et est revenu
notamment l'expérience vous avez plus de
trente années de politique derrière vous
des mandats locaux départementaux et
nationaux
cette expérience est une force et
qu'elle est nécessaire cette expérience
après les échecs de la présidentielle
des législatives
n'essayez pas de me rajeunir abusivement
j'ai 60 ans donc je n'ai pas 30 ans
d'expérience politique j'ai plus de 40
ans de plus de 40 ans parce que j'ai 40
ans de militantisme et ma première
expérience politique si je suis d'abord
un militant militer c'est croire à des
idées c'est porter les valeurs et je
suis restée tout au long de ma vie
politique avec ses hauts ses bas
un militant au fond du coeur voilà donc
maintenant oui ce côté vintage fait que
je pense que je peux apporter de
l'expérience et qu'on a besoin
d'expérience on a entendu le message à
l'occasion de la dernière élection
présidentielle et des élections
législatives
il faut renouveler bien entendu mais on
fait pas du renouveau comme ça on fait
du renouveau en l'organisant or ya eu le
renouveau lié à l'extraordinaire
chapitre de l'élection présidentielle
avec pour la première fois dans notre
histoire notre élimination premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle qui a eu un
effet dévastateur sur nos élections
législatives mais ça n'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut comme l'a fait de
monsieur macron sortir des candidats
comme ça au petit bonheur la chance
est ce que vous êtes capables vous même
en tant que journaliste éminent de ce
département de nos cités par coeur le
nom de tous les députés et les rêves m
j'en suis pas totalement sûr en tout cas
moi j'en suis incapable et je peux vous
dire que tous les illilois que je
rencontre ont sont aussi incapable bon
ce sont des gens qui viennent de nulle
part qui ont bien souvent une
méconnaissance criante du terme
certains même pendant la campagne
électorale est tracté sur des marchés
dans des communes qui n'étaient pas dans
leur circonscription donc on ne peut pas
partir de rien voilà du passé ne faisons
pas table rase et donc profitons
peut-être de l'expérience ce que j'ai
c'est le privilège juste une question
encore sur cette thématique vous aurez
face à vous
en octobre notamment la vice présidente
du conseil régional et alexandra du
blanche avec à ses côtés le conseiller
régional
othman nasri qui a reçu le soutien
notamment de valérie pécresse est ce que
ce duel
selon vous c'est l'expression peut-être
de tension sans la fédération au
contraire l'expression pluralité il ya
des pluralités au sein du parti des
républicains et elle s'exprime avec ce
scrutin
moi je fais pas de langue de bois je
pense peut il eût mieux valu comme je
les propose et alexandra et à hotfile
qu'on intègre qu'on les intègre dans
l'équipe bon ils ne l'ont pas voulu
alexandra m'a expliqué que voilà la
diversité de candidature c'était bien ce
n'est pas ce que me disent nos militants
nos militants c'est des grands brûlés
après la débâcle d'inconnus ils ont
envie d'autre chose que ce qui leur
paraît être un peu des tensions internes
voilà et poursuivies hors essence
éléments de nature en octobre
traditionnellement dans le département
des yvelines on se mettait d'accord et
on essayait de constituer des équipes
unis bon ça n'est pas possible cette
fois c'est vrai que il ya des stratégies
partisanes
il ya des stratégies présidentielles qui
nous font grand mal l'élection
présidentielle elle est pour après des
élections municipales après les
élections départementales après des
élections régionales
on a bien le temps de d'abord nous
préparer à nos différentes échéances
électorales avant d'aborder cette
échéance présidentielle ben c'est ainsi
on fera avec
et cette élection le rappel elle est
prévue en octobre un autre événement qui
arrivent sur le territoire
un peu plus loin c'est les jeux
olympiques en 2024 à paris également
dans les yvelines
on les surnomme la génération 2024 les
écoliers et collégiens d'aujourd'hui
construisent leur parcours scolaire en
même temps que l'échéance djo approche
pour favoriser la pratique sportive des
plus jeunes et leur permettre de se
faire une place dans un tel événement
l'éducation nationale multiplie les
partenariats
aujourd'hui l'académie de versailles
signé l'un d'eux avec la fédération
française de cyclisme celui ci doit
permettre de développer est la pratique
du sport des scolaires et leurs
connaissances également écoutez à ce
propos le recteur de l'académie au micro
de nicolas kirillovitch les enfants qui
entre en cp et ceux qui entrent en
sixième ce qui entre en seconde
tous ces élèves et
vont être des élèves qui vont connaître
les jeux olympiques et les jeux
paralympiques et dans une vie c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir eu à connaître ça
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
nous nous mobilisions avec les
professeurs les responsables de sections
sportives les fédérations pour que nous
développions l'envi de sport
la passion du sport et puis aussi ce que
le sport veut dire dans un parcours
scolaire pierre bédier légion qui
prendront pleinement part dans le
département avec des épreuves organisées
à versailles saint quentin en yvelines
on parle du cyclisme de gold vtt
notamment
c'est une véritable chance pour les
yvelines cgo c'est formidable pour
l'image des yvelines mais je voudrais
surtout dire aux yvelines - c'est
formidable pour les yvelinois
d'abord parce que faire parler de leur
département en bien le faire voir sous
c'est son plus beau jour
c'est bien mais aussi il faut qu'il
participe parce que moi j'ai eu
l'occasion j'ai découvert les jeux
olympiques à atlanta en 1996
je n'ai qu'un regret c'est de ne pas
avoir pu faire d'autre et de naître et
c't'à ton sac 48 heures c'est une
ambiance mais merveilleuses
extraordinaire c'est un un foisonnement
d'animations de rencontres de détente
c'est sans doute l'événement sportif
numéro 1 encore supérieur à la coupe du
monde de football qui y participent vous
le dites mais qui aussi que cela leur
profite à plus long terme que ce soit
pas seulement au moment de ces jeux
olympiques
d'abord alors je pense que pour profiter
le département des yvelines a été si
j'ose le dire puisque je n'ai aucune
responsabilité à ces malaises puisque
lorsqu'il ya eu déjà des candidatures on
s'est doté des équipements et donc dans
le département des yvelines vous savez
c'est un reproche qui est souvent fait
aux jeux olympiques c'est qu'après les
jeux y'a plus rien voir des équipements
qui restent en jachère
or nous le golf national basse et il est
là et il est bien là et qu'il entend
bien rester
et puis le cyclisme le cyclone avec le
vélodrome mais pas qu'avec le vélodrome
et je peux vous garantir que parce que
jean-michel fond rouge m'a beaucoup
sensibilisé sur ce dossier nous allons
porter d'ici aux jeux olympiques de 2024
une animation sportive très forte dans
le département autour du cyclisme parce
que le cyclisme c'est du sport mais
aussi du loisir et c'est aussi
le très grand sportif mais madame ou
monsieur tout le monde un événement qui
profiteront l'a compris au département
alors dans le reste de l'actualité
c'est en ce moment la 16e édition de la
semaine européenne du développement
durable cette année elle est placée sous
la thématique nationale villes et
territoires de demain
à cette occasion diverses manifestations
sont proposées sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines qui organise
ces semaines dédiées
jusqu'au 5 juin un reportage de manon
varaldo des images de nicolas landry et
patrick jacques de dixmude on conserve
sa réfléchir à l'impact de nos gestes au
quotidien insisté sur le tri des déchets
un des objectifs de cette semaine du
développement durable
attrape une journée de l'environnement a
été mise en place
aujourd'hui on met en valeur surtout
notre centre technique municipal
on a mis en place des panneaux qui
explique l'historique de ce centre et on
a également une main on voulait mettre
en place des ateliers en lien avec la
biodiversité sensibilisation aux déchets
mais aussi atelier jardinage visite des
animaux ou encore sculpture autant
d'activités proposées pour tous les âges
dans le cadre de cette semaine du
développement durable avec la
possibilité de déguster des produits bio
venus pour rejouer et apprend des trucs
pour trier et pour un premier peloton et
la nature les enfants notamment apprécié
l'atelier jardinage où ils avaient la
possibilité de repartir avec leurs
plantes
ça consiste à les initier à la
plantation c'est-à-dire à transvaser le
planqué dans un godet qui étaient
achetés on dans une jardinerie en
général et
à la 3 et si vous voulez dans un
contenant un peu plus haut voilà et
tout en leur expliquant le procédé
et on les dit dans avoise 1 le
bretonneux c'est pour eux la deuxième
édition de la semaine du développement
à cette occasion un atelier cuisine afin
de lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire s'est déroulée en
partenariat avec l'association jardins
opération partage sa de matinée c'est de
permettre à des seigneurs de pouvoir
élaborer un plat rapidement on va dire
une heure et demie avec une entrée un
plat un dessert sur la table différents
éléments ont des paniers garnis chacun
choisit ses éléments à commencer par
réfléchir à ses besoins la semaine du
développement durable se poursuit
jusqu'au 5 juin sur tout le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
alors ça cela fait partie des
compétences du département l'aménagement
durable pierre bédier comment la
collectivité des yvelines agi talent en
faveur de l'environnement et du
développement durable le développement
durable c'est multi c'est trailer tout
et c'est très très la la la préservation
notamment des espaces naturels sensibles
nous on est très engagé effectivement
dans une politique de préservation des
espaces naturels sensibles mais sur tous
les sujets et nos bâtiments maintenant
lorsqu'on construit des bâtiments
lorsqu'on les rénove on s'arrange pour
qu'il soit sous autonome soit autonome
soit en dessous consommation énergétique
dans la façon de faire nos routes aussi
enfin je crois que le développement
durable
sa caractéristique aujourd'hui c'est que
un peu comme la proche de monsieur
jourdain
tout le monde doit en faire alors
parlons de l'action du département et
lingots combat actuel depuis quelques
mois elle les yvelines et et ses voisins
franciliens sont mobilisés contre la
réforme de la métropole du grand paris
elle est envisagée donc par le
gouvernement est envisagé la disparition
de trois départements de la petite
couronne 92 93 et 94 au profit de la
métropole sans prendre en compte les
départements de la grande couronne les
arbitrages n'ont pas été encore rendu
sur le sujet vous pierre bédier
comme vos collègues présidente
département vous prenez une métropole
régionale
exactement et comme la présente deux
régions aussi puisque nous sommes
unanimes
sur sur ce sujet parce que c'est la
bonne échelle
comment peut-on imaginer indépendamment
des habitants qui souvent vivent en
grande couronne et vont travailler en
petite couronne donc on va quand même
pas leur demander comme en chine un
permis de circuler pour aller travailler
et puis on a des équipes grande couronne
où des des projets qui à l'évidence son
intérêt metropolit je n'en prendrai
qu'un qui est à côté d'ici le plateau de
saclay on a expliqué qu'on allait faire
là le lieu de l'intelligence et de la
formation à l'échelle mondiale pour la
france et ça n'est pas dans la métropole
ça n'a aucun sens et l'argument qui est
utilisée par certains pros métropole qui
consiste à dire mais il ya trop
d'espacés ruraux mais on vient de parler
de développement durable
justement ces espaces ordre ou cette
agriculture sont une richesse dans la
métropole
retenant une chose de toutes les
métropoles mondiales
l'originalité de la métropole française
serait qu'elle serait la seule à avoir
des terres agricoles et être une
puissance agricole à un moment où la
nourriture la nourriture saine sont des
enjeux essentiels est un sujet est
important de le noter qui met d'accord
en tout cas tous les présidents des
départements franciliens et de toutes
les gauches gratte plr tout le monde est
d'accord
alors ce schéma s'il voit le jour ce
schéma du gouvernement pourrait anéantir
le projet de rapprochement entre les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine la fusion
entre les yvelines et aux scènes c'est
une démarche que vous avez entreprise
avec votre homologue patrick devedjian
il ya deux ans les départements ces deux
départements se sont réunis au sein
d'une pays un établissement public
interdépartemental certaines compétences
ont d'ailleurs été mutualisés par
exemple la voirie demain se tient un
conseil d'administration sept pays où en
est le projet aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il est remis en question le projet se
poursuit
j'annoncerai d'ailleurs comme patrick à
l'occasion de nos séances de juin qu'on
veut même aller plus loin parce que nous
sommes vraiment convaincu que nous
sommes en train de construire à l'ouest
une un pôle politique
un pôle institutionnel extrêmement
puissant et tournée vers le
développement économique et nous
considérons que en région parisienne
si nous ne nous saisissons pas de ce
dossier du développement économique
alors que à l'évidence d'autres
territoires sont soit moins favorisés
soit dans le fond pas une priorité
je pense en particulier à paris est bien
le problème de l'emploi persistera
parce que son développement économique
qui n'a pas d'emploi et si ce schéma de
métropole du grand paris voulu par le
gouvernement voie le jour ça ça met fin
totalement à ce projet attendre attendre
avant son faisons la démonstration par
la preuve que notre affaire marche
certains disent que ça que génère pas
d'économie nous démontrons qu'au
contraire ça génère des économies mais
bon il ya aussi des jeux tactiques et
politique
et ça donne surtout beaucoup de
puissance pour porter des projets sans
être obligé d'aller attendre que l'état
des finances l'état n'a plus d'argent je
je disais j'avais une réunion cet après
midi avec les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines puisque nous allons bientôt
signer un contrat territorial
d'importance et je leur disais que cette
fusion si elle existait eh bien nous
pourrions faire tout seul sans l'aide de
l'état
la ligne 18 parce que aujourd'hui une
capacité d'investissement qui serait
tellement considérables que ça ne
poserait pas de problèmes budgétaires
pas de problème financier donc en
quelque sorte j'ai envie de dire à
l'état oublié nous laisser nous faire et
on vous oubliera puisque vous ne pouvez
pas grand chose pour vous une dernière
question à ceux qui étaient les plus
légers à ce que vous êtes un amateur de
plantes et de jardinage pour m'aider je
peux vous faire une confidence elle
j'adore les plantes
je ne jardine pas parce que je pas
beaucoup le temps depuis ces pannes
extérieur mais j'ai un bureau chez moi
que j'ai un peu aménagée à mon goût et
dans lequel j'ai profusion de plantes
vertes et je dois avoir la main verte
parce que elle prospère c'est en tout
cas la grande tendance du moment le
cactus a envahi les intérieurs depuis
plusieurs mois et même quelques années
elle les yvelines ne sont pas passés à
côté de ce phénomène végétal vous allez
le voir dans ce sujet les commerçants
tentent même de surfer sur cette mode
manon varaldo me calomnier d'euros
conseiller du cou à cette période
comment compactus comme chaque semaine
money devient repérer les derniers
arrivages de cactus en grande passionnée
cette vue en courtoise en possède une
dizaine chez elle il ya beaucoup de
variétés ça permet aussi d'avoir des
plantes toute l'année qui durent clean
qui reste fleuris ou pas fleuri monique
n'est pas la seule à avoir été piqué par
la fièvre du cactus magasins en vend 500
chaque semaine à partir du printemps
pour un chiffre d'affaires de 2000 euros
hebdomadaires leur best seller les
miniatures qui fonctionne très bien ici
c'est des petits captifs que vous avez
là par exemple
tous ces modèles là comme ceci avec des
petites fleurs qui sont très attrayantes
ceci également alors ça ça s'appelle les
gymnopédies ciom ça des cactus qui sont
qui sont greffés premier cactus et la
boule à les greffer dessus des
miniatures qu'on peut également observer
à la borie tome de versailles chèvre ou
loi rocancourt en compagnie de trois
cents autres espèces de cactus mais qui
n'ose rsa enfin fleury j'adore ces
fleurs elles sont magnifiques
pour les spécialistes qui travaillent
dans la structure l'engouement autour de
ces plantes commencé il ya six ans ne
risque pas de s'essouffler il correspond
parfaitement aux envies du public
ils ont tellement des formes différentes
des couleurs différentes que il y en a
une palette assez impressionnante
il y en a pour tous les goûts alors je
pense aussi que le cactus a un avantage
c'est que l'entretien est très facile a
pas beaucoup d'arrosage
ils tolèrent à peu près tout ils peuvent
partir en vacances tranquilles leurs
plantes elles resteront en bon état et
il n'y a pas de soucis quoi une passion
pour le cactus qui s'exporte également
chez les restaurants évinois dans ce
concept store de montfort l'amaury
ouvert il ya seulement quelques mois
la plante est présente dans tous les
recoins sa présence devient même un
argument marketing
on suppose que ça plaira inspiré mais
moi j'aime
j'aime bien ça me fait penser un peu
dans le haut des airs et j'aime beaucoup
le désert voilà je pense que les gens
pour que ce restaurant se transforme
encore un peu plus son désert américain
les propriétaires vont recevoir dans les
prochains jours une livraison de
plusieurs dizaines de cactus le
restaurant prévoit également de préparer
des boissons et des planons piquant à
base de cette plante
c'est la fin de ce journal en édition
spéciale ce soir merci pierre bédier
d'abord né à ses hameaux président du
conseil départemental des yvelines et je
rappelle candidat pour reprendre la tête
de la fédération des républicains dans
les yvelines l'élection doit se tenir en
octobre
cette édition elle est à revoir sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]